massé merci nous accorder un peu de
temps à cette fin de campagne
on peut vraiment plaisir d'être avec
vous passez vos idées sont disons
rafraîchissant par tout cas elles
plaisent visiblement a de plus en plus
d'électeurs mais il ya quand même une
question qui demeure dans la tête de
bien des gens est ce que c'est réaliste
je vais prendre juste un exemple et les
gens des régions sommes excusés mais je
vais prendre le transport collectif à
montréal
vous dites on va injecter 10 milliards
dans le premier mandat 38 stations de
métro on rêve vraiment vous fait rêver
mais est-ce que c'est faisable quand on
sait que ça a pris et ce depuis dix ans
on n'a pas eu une - oui en fait c'est
réaliste quand il est la volonté
politique derrière vous savez pour nous
à québec solidaire l'urgence climatique
nécessite qu'on met tous les moyens
nécessaires pour qu'on fasse notre pas
ici au québec et le transport des
individus c'est de loin ce qui est le
plus producteur de gaz à effet de serre
alors nous ont dit on prend le problème
à bras le corps on donne le virage
nécessaire et les 38 stations vous
comprenez bien seront pas construites en
quatre ans mais les chantiers vont être
enclenchée et oui le projet du grand
montréal express ben il va naître sous
un québec solidaire mais vous voulez
financer vos promesses notamment en
taxant les grandes entreprises
est-ce que vous avez mesuré l'impact que
cela peut avoir sur la capacité du
québec à maintenir ses à garder ces
entreprises ici parce que on vit pas en
vase clos absolument on est d'accord
avec vous là dessus mais il faut aussi
que la grande entreprise fasse talent
juste pas puisqu'elle bénéficie des
travailleurs travailleuses formé par
notre système d'éducation d'un système
de sécurité publique d'un système de
santé à 7,1 il faut que il fait il faut
qu'elles fassent leur part mais je
rappelle à la population que la grande
entreprise au début du 20e siècle 21e
siècle pardon était était imposé à 30%
nous on suggère de passer de 11,7 à 14,5
on n'est pas là dans quelque chose
d'impossible et au contraire je pense
que pour améliorer tout ça on va leur
offrir du monde
qui vont être mieux formés qui aient des
enfants qui vont être plus en santé pour
leurs travailleurs et travailleuses plus
dansantes et au niveau de bucco dentaire
mais ça fait quand même une différence
quand même au point de différence
six entreprises là peuvent fermer c'est
des emplois quand même que l'entreprise
souhaite c'est de la prévisibilité ans
nous ont dit que sur l'espace de cinq
ans de mandat
on va passer de 11 à 2,7 à à 14,5 ce
qu'on dit c'est oui on eu le courage
politique de faire ça et vous savez
prenons par exemple les ressources
naturelles
ils vont pas déménager nos ressources
naturelles ils vont rester au québec
elles sont au québec ces ressources on
pense que les entreprises aussi ça se
peut qu en aucun temps qui passe mais en
moins vous même qu'elle peut on a perdu
rhône on a perdu saint-hubert on a perdu
plein d'entreprises rester poli 150 et
ce soir on a du mal à savoir vraiment
quel rôle va jouer les top si québec
solidaire le du mal à définir aussi ce
parti là comment vous vous le définissez
parce que je sais qu'il ya eu une sorte
d'étiquette qui ont été lancés vous
aimez pas ça mais vous comment vous le
définissez québec solidaire ben pour moi
c'est clair ce pourquoi on ne fonde east
partie de l'oeil à 12
c'est parce qu'on trouvait que les vieux
parti faisait plus leur travail pour
prendre soin des gens de tous les gens
pas seulement des sucs sont en haut de
l'échelle où les plus pauvres qui sont
vraiment à l'échelle de l'ensemble de la
population à travers les services
publics à travers la redistribution des
richesses
moi je pense juste que québec solidaire
vient dire au québec on est capable
d'intervenir dans l'économie notamment
parce que c'est votre préoccupation pour
permettre un développement économique au
service de tout le monde et non pas
seulement par exemple au service des
multinationales qui retire les
ressources naturelles de notre sol et
les envois se faire transformer à
l'extérieur en nous on veut pas tout non
nationalisés
ce qu'on veut c'est par exemple le
lithium qui actuellement 1
ça s'était dans un premier mandat ça
serait dans notre premier mandat
effectivement qui est une ressource
essentielle à la transition énergétique
puisque ça composent les batteries que
pour pour stocker l'électricité qui font
déplacer les voitures bondir à anouar
diba on a au québec du lithium
voilà québec solidaire veut prendre le
contrôle public par la nationalisation
on veut prendre la nationalisation non
c'est 5 en plus sont donc le contrôle
public donc dire qu'on va avoir un
partenaire économique là dedans privé
est ensemble on va extraire le lithium
on va le transformer au québec on va
construire des batteries
on va recycler nos batteries et on va
faire un c'est complet mais pas en chine
ici au québec il ya cette chicane à ces
publics entre québec solidaire et le
parti québécois on sait que vous aviez
refusé la convergence avec le parti
québécois
visiblement jean françois lisée a pas
tellement apprécié la ja gilles duceppe
qui en remet aujourd'hui et qui met en
cause vos qualités de leadership en fait
la qualité de votre français il s'en
prend assez durement à vous qu'est ce
que vous répondez écouter ou m'ont
personnellement est attaqué de toutes
parts c'est l'histoire de ma vie mais je
trouve ça profondément respectueux pour
les gens qui viennent pas nécessairement
de l'élite et je pense que moi quand
j'ai décidé de faire la politique est
d'aller au niveau de la politique du
gouvernement
au niveau du québec c'est justement le
signal que je voulais envoyer c'est la
politique ce n'est pas la seule affaire
de l'élite ça nous appartient à tout le
peuple et moi je suis fier d'ogier et ce
monsieur
visait duceppe trouve que c'est pas
digne
moi je pense qu'il faut que s'adresse
aux gens parce que manger du monde
ordinaire
donc il ya pas de rapprochement possible
entre souverainistes entre progrès 6
avec le parti québécois parce que dans
certaines certaines circonscriptions
vous réalisez bien que ça peut peut-être
laissé passer un libéral ou un cas
qu'ils oui mais c'est ça le propre la
politique madame galipeau on a au québec
une vingtaine de partis politiques dont
quatre qui sont présentement représentés
à l'assemblée nationale c'est ça le jeu
de la politique c'est nous on a des
idées on sait que les autres aucun autre
parti propose nous des mêmes
l'indépendance et pas soutenu par
monsieur lisez de la même façon nous on
propose que soit la souveraineté du
peuple qu'ils soient mises de l'avant
même s'il soutient pas alors pourquoi on
se dirait quelqu'un comme ça qu'ils ont
vécu au gré du vent par don rées en
ligne son tir pour avoir des votes
non nous on est constant depuis douze
ans et la mère a franchement pas sur des
dossiers ça a toujours été ça le rend
cas sur des choses spécifiques
le jour on va mettre en marche le
processus de l'indépendance du québec
jeu certains comment le faire ensemble
mais ceci je pense que monsieur lisez
doit s'en mordre les doigts
le parti québécois doit s'en mordre les
doigts le mode de scrutin piège des
électeurs et voici un nom des pièges
dans lesquels ils ont pris d'ailleurs si
vous avez éventuellement la balance du
pouvoir là dans ces élections et pass 4
jours maintenant ça serait une de vos
priorités seul ce serait l une de vos
demandes en tout cas bien ce qu large et
monsieur legault et monsieur lisez se
sont engagés à faire la réforme du mode
de scrutin dans la première année de
leur gouvernement s'il prenait pouvoir
nous c'est dans notre programme depuis
toujours parce qu'on croit à la
démocratie
c'est ça la démocratie c'est que chaque
vote quand alors c'est clair que pour
nous c'est un incontournable et on
espère qu'ils vont respecter leur parole
je souhaitais madame masse et une bonne
fin de campagne
merci beaucoup